your take on it well I think the first
thing is that the authorities have
really effectively got to put the city
into lockdown and establish exactly what
has happened and how many hostile people
are out there and who they are
so the message they're putting out to
the public is look after yourself avoid
public places stop where you are be it
go into a shock goes into a cafe try and
keep out at the sight of any windows and
and unlock the doors so that it becomes
a very difficult place for any gunman
who might be out there to operate so
what you'll have is you'll have they
need to clear the streets so that the
emergency services can move freely and
the priority will obviously be dealing
with the injured there'll be the second
set who are now trying very very hard to
establish what happened and to
neutralize as it were that those those
gunmen who are out there so and then
there'll be a third group of people who
will move in behind all of this who will
be investigators and they will already
be trying to establish who these guys
are in in a more intelligence-led way
really they'll have CCTV they will most
definitely be talking to I witness --is
and to people who were maybe walking
wounded who were actually involved in it
and I can remember after for example the
21-7 attempted bombings in London being
at the scene of one as it just after it
had happened and and suddenly there was
a woman in jeans standing up shouting
anyone who saw anything come here now
trying to get that type of information
so that very quickly they can start
following whoever they may be back to
their homes for example and then of
course treat them with caution because
they may well as well as shooting people
they may well have to do is find vests
that sort of thing